[Musique]
des gens étranges dans un étrange ennemi rachel
bombarde Londres pendant toute la guerre
il vous a été difficile de vous attendre à
ce que cette maison soit réquisitionnée pour un
usage britannique sur ordre de la Commission de contrôle
c'est votre maison je t'aime n'ai-je pas
peut-être pas une manifestation extérieure de haine les
cantonnements là-bas sous la surface
faites attention ils ne nous aiment pas pendant la
guerre avez-vous déjà espéré une
victoire allemande je voulais revenir à ce que
c'était ma femme elle est morte dans la
tempête de feu
vous  ne m'a pas dit dans quoi j'entrais
ce n'est pas comme ça que c'était censé
être aucun de nous n'est censé être à l'extérieur
s'il vous plait n'y allez pas j'ai un travail à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
ça irait, tout recommencerait
Oh